welcome back to a ladder with Crowder
my next guest we thought what was the
best way to round out the end of the
year here and we had to have on one of
our all-time favorite guests you can
find her all over the interwebs you can
read her books nearly every book
releases his best-selling Michelle
Malkin comma she'll milk and thank you
so much for being back well thanks for
having me I've always glad to have you
on now we were talking about this your
kids are growing up right and it's
Christmas so do you find as a parent is
Christmas less fun than it used to be or
does it just sort of transition into
something else
well yeah it's definitely we're at the
transition stage my daughter's 14 now
and my son is 11 and had a revelation on
his own then that the Santa was not real
that's okay it's all good
you know but I don't know it's a little
bit melancholy for me to get to this
stage on the on the other hand and
they're becoming young adults and that's
just a you know another another step in
the in this wonderful journey of
parenthood right I know it well you seem
to have raised some fine young adults I
don't mean to get personal but I've
obviously spent time with a family and
you know it's it's funny in this
industry you know this Michelle we can
have we can meet so many phonies
so having spent time with your family to
see that you guys are true blue and just
you know they actually like you guys
they actually like their parents and you
like your kids it's a rarity so you must
be doing something right well that's the
best Christmas gift of all and I have to
say and I men up and I'm not second up
here Steven but they are huge fans of
yours so we must have done something
right right no no that makes me question
everything I've just said I think you're
just if you're showing them any of my
content you've made a horrible mistake
but so speaking of content so you've
you've written a lot I mean there's so
much to talk about this week we have
North Korea and Seth Rogen and James
Franco but here's one thing obviously
you wrote about Jeb Bush a lot of
different viewpoints on Jeb Bush running
some people are thrilled of course and
some people think he's establishment
type you wrote about this what's your
take on Jeb Bush I guess is this do we
officially call it exploratory time now
I don't know yeah well did that that was
his announcement on on Facebook and
Twitter this week that he was quote
actively exploring the possibility of
running for president blah blah blah
I am NOT a fan and I have not been a fan
of Jeb bushes for a long long time I
think that the main argument from the
salons from the DC establishment and the
the strategists and the navel gaze
earthen in Washington and Manhattan
their argument will be that he has a
solidly conservative record as Florida
Governor and I think that they're going
to use that as a shield to try and
immunize him from criticism from the
grassroots on the right on to of really
two of my defining national public
policy issues education and immigration
and on those issues Jeb Bush finds
himself in the same camp as many big
government and big business progressive
right he's for common core and he is
squarely and unapologetically for some
kind of mass legalization for he need
millions of illegal aliens he's also in
support of massive expansions of
temporary visas for h-1b holders and I
have to question the the wisdom and the
lack of principle in supporting these
policies that are not good for American
parents not good for American students
not good for the current generation of
American workers how dare you how dare
you question I think about that the
knowledge of the bushes
you know it's funny we've never gotten
more hate calls Michelle then you know I
fill in for Bennett Bill Bennett he has
a morning show that he runs nationally
and he takes Friday's off so Bill
Bennett has never been on air in Detroit
ever and I mentioned one time that he
you know actually sat in the floor with
Jeb Bush supporting Common Core and that
I think Bennett's a good guy I think
Bush is actually I think he's probably a
good man but I do think Common Core is
one of those litmus tests I don't think
there are any litmus test that should
determine whether you're a conservative
or not but I think you know obvious
the abortion is one but common core is
one of those things it's as close to a
litmus test I think that we have for
Republicans to see if they actually
believe in constitutional parameters of
government and I don't know if I'm the
only one who thinks that I just think
it's a really good barometer and it's so
telling that you mentioned that with
Bush yes you said that very well and
I've been reporting on jeb Bush's
spearheading and profiting from common
core for years now I've talked about how
he's used his nonprofit the foundation
for educational excellence sounds so
good doesn't it as a way it doesn't
sound bad as a way to pander to
corporate interests many of whom are
benefitting from the common core racket
and the taxpayer-funded monopoly of
textbooks and testing companies that
have been behind this right I and I and
I think it's not just that he has been
at the forefront of something that goes
against the grain of cherished principle
of local autonomy and sovereignty over
educational issues the constitutional
principle obviously that you just
mentioned but it's also the way in which
that he's dealt with opponents and it
has this progressive elitist feel to it
the way he has attacked grassroots
parents in Florida and and the rest of
the country
who have realized I want to get on
privacy under my undermining a privacy
sabotaging racket that's all it is
right why why not because you touched on
that and a lot of people don't know that
and they think that I'm just being
anti-establishment for the sake of it
and I think you've gotten that a lot too
Michelle a lot of people don't give you
enough credit you know the libertarians
who just wanted to smoke a bunch of pot
I think we're then surprised when you
came out and you had a very reason view
on medical marijuana they're like well
now we have to find out another reason
to hate her the same with making right I
talk about this a lot you mentioned
specifically Jeb Bush in the Bush family
and by the way wartime president I have
all the respect in the world for
president george w bush with 9/11 so let
me preface it with that
but you mentioned him attacking
activists you know essentially the mom
who was against common core a lot of
people don't know that maybe for the
listener who doesn't know - tell us
about that because it can get ugly yeah
well I think the best thing to do for
listeners who are not familiar with this
long record on this is to go to my
website at michelle malkin calm and
being - in the search engine common core
Jeb Bush and you'll find snip fit after
Schmitt fit of Jeb Bush accusing parents
like me and there are millions of us who
have Grant on the ground experience with
how Common Core at usurped local control
sabotage already pre-existing standards
of academic excellence in our own
backyards and local communities and how
he has attacked us for opposing academic
excellence and not knowing what's best
for our own children and it's that kind
of nanny state elitism that obviously we
expect from the left from Hillary
Clinton and No Child Left Behind it and
it takes a village in all that but for
someone who pretends to be a promoter of
school choice and that is that is how
Jeb Bush has captured the hearts of so
many establishment Republicans and
establishment GOP pundits and the East
Coast and for him to not see that these
two things cannot it's cognitive dismiss
you cannot be for school choice and
common core at the same time it's insane
I think I think my brain just had an
aneurysm for a second I don't fully
process that it's true it's one thing
listen everyone wants schools to be
better right everyone wants kids to do
better in school they want kids to learn
more what people don't understand and
you've written about this so much at
your website for those who haven't go to
Michelle Malkin calm it's a federal
power grab and the federal government
doesn't know how to best educate your
children a better than you know Michelle
Malkin knows how to educate her children
but then your state and your
municipality and to remove that ability
to remove that authority from municipal
governments that's a big power grab with
which conservative
shouldn't be comfortable so when I see
someone like a Jeb Bush or a Bill
Bennett out there really actively
supporting it how do you think they
expect to rally the conservative base or
do they just not care they don't care
and I think it's because there has been
such a lack of accountability and and
and the fact that you know I think there
are a lot of loyal grassroots
conservatives out there who have
swallowed hard in so many of the past
presidential election cycles they've
been sold on the idea that well we need
someone who's more reasonable sounding
and pragmatic and we can figure we can't
have actually somebody who has put the
pedal to the metal on the conservative
principles because oh that won't be
palpable well how did that work out on
my bowl she's not worked out with John
McCain on that note Michele hold on one
second we have to go to break and I want
to bring you back because you are on
fire
stay tuned louder with Crowder Michelle
Malkin and we're back with the one and
only Michelle Malkin who was on fire
firstly credit to you for bringing out a
Bob Dole reference in 2014 I can't
remember the last time I heard his name
Bob Dole Bob Dole says Bob Dole he's
just sitting in his pants watching that
Britney Spears Pepsi commercial saying
Bob Dole who told him it was a good idea
to do the viagra was a viagra commercial
that he did I don't know so you know
what's funny is there some Karl Rove
type behind the scenes going no this is
gonna be great for you kid no one can
touch you the viagra commercial with
Britney Spears this the new Republican
point and then more we looked at like
worthy idiots because we believe in
common-sense values in limited
government
I want to pivot Michelle because this is
something you wrote about recently again
at Michelle Malkin calm though I don't
want to be insensitive because when I
talk about these issues my white
privilege is showing as a male Michelle
Obama went through a very traumatizing
incident at Target where she was talking
about how racial tensions are still
alive and someone asked her
to help her get something from the shelf
I don't want to be inaccurate because
Michelle you have more of a minority
pass than I do so perhaps you can
explain for the listener yeah that's
right I've got the brown skin
perpetrated Vokoun right now this whole
episode is is ridiculous on its face and
offensive when you when you scratch the
surface just a little bit
well mrs. Obama had this exclusive
interview with People magazine the
context is important here because she
was trying to show she was down with the
struggle of the post Ferguson agitators
so she illuminated all of these specific
horrific examples of the vestages of
racism that still exists and that both
she and her privileged husband still
suffer from she talked about this very
famous it's infamous now it turned into
this incident a couple of years ago in
2012 when she supposedly went on
incognito to be among the regular mom
the target and some shopper asked her to
go reach the detergent high up on the
shelf and all of a sudden misting has
morphed into an example of her being an
oppressed martyr and and and symbol of
of racial discrimination although when
she whispered counted this story on the
David Letterman Show shortly after the
target visit
it's very strange you can go watch the
video where she related the same
anecdote that's just a nice little
example of how she's among the hoi
polloi what happened here an incredible
tall tale of racialized victimhood and
the thing is Steven and I wrote about
this one culture of corruption I did a
whole chapter on Michelle Obama where I
talked about this penchant that she has
for spinning these tales of racial
oppression for political games very
doing it since she was a Princeton
University and I read her thesis it was
called Princeton educated blacks and the
black community and she talked about how
she was being marginalized by the
lily-white academic tower ivory
power and how she had suffered
afterwards after she graduated with a
lily-white a corporate world when in
fact she had benefited time and time
again from the largesse of the American
Dream and all she can do is whine about
it all the way to the tippy top of the
ladder of opportunity I don't know I
don't know if I'm comfortable with this
because people are going to see this on
YouTube and you're not on camera it's
just me this large white man and people
will associate what you're saying and
you could say it but I can't say it
they're going to blame me and it will in
quotations say Michelle Malkin you know
I honestly if I were in a store I'll be
honest ok Michelle
firstly I would never ask you to get
something in the top shelf because I
would be mad in the be challenged and
that's racist I get it believe me it's
not lost on me that I'm a racist jerk ok
but Michelle Obama is constantly walking
or everything is sleeveless right she
wants to show you the horseshoe tricep
she has going on so if I'm just looking
for someone who looks like they are of
good stock to help carry something heavy
from a high shelf she's got the reach
and she's obviously showing her arms I
would think that it'd be complimentary
for me to say hey sweetheart you've got
great arms you could help me carry
something heavy and I just realized
sweetheart is also sexist I say it all
the time to my wife and I just realize
now now I'll be condemned for that but
you know I mean it seems to me I can't
imagine someone construing that as
racist is it do we even know if this guy
was white who asked her did she clarify
it was it was a woman Oh a woman that's
right yeah and and of course the second
is you know another point here is the
reason why you wouldn't ask me to get
you anything is because I'm 5 foot 1 and
Michelle Obama's 5 foot 11 oh you know
the idea that is Jim Crow all over again
some shorter person asked her to go
reach the detergent on the top shelf
well if that's true then every recruiter
for the WNBA needs to be hauled out in
cuffs
I mean hey you're tall and you know we
need you to shoot we need you to shoot a
jumper over another effectively what is
a giant if they would have described
Michelle Obama or my wife in the old
test
they would have been a giant right 511
for a woman is incredibly tall she's
like the bumble in Rudolph the Red Nosed
Reindeer putting the star on the
Christmas tree
I just you know he'll you know
ultimately I think what the shows is
it's not about the color of the skin of
Barack or Michelle Obama it really is
about the thinness of their skin and you
know setting aside that this is a
completely tall tale pun intended as the
idea that somebody asking her for a
favor is tantamount to an international
human rights crime it just shows you
that the level of cynicism that just
reeks that marinates the this whole
identity politics culture that they're
involved in oh yeah yeah why are you
okay do you need to take a minute can I
ask you for one that's not racist or
sexist I don't know racist or sexist we
it's it's one of those things where it's
you know I want to think that I'm not
out of touch because I'm white but I do
understand there are certain things as a
white male that I may not experience you
know I fully grasp that I fully
comprehend that I can never have the
same experience in America as you did
you know growing up it's funny you say
Brown as a Filipino you know obviously
there's usually people would say you
know Asians yellow is Filipino separated
into brown if you're going to go into a
color yeah well I'm a little Brown woman
don't you know
okay let's I guess I don't see it that
way but uh I guess but you're not like
anyone's gonna say well I think it's
because it's Southeast Asia but you know
in any case I think the thing that up
that I've learned from my days at you
know wacky Oberlin College and and for
the last quarter century really dealing
with the identity politics left is they
have to reach they have to reach so far
and so hard and they end up fabricating
so much of the discrimination they need
to do it I mean Oberlin is a cesspool of
racial hoaxes
and and I think that there is a
connection here to all of the gender
hoaxes that we're seeing as well with
all of the the you know these hyped rape
claims that are falling apart and it's
been happening for years and years now I
think the difference is that and this is
heartening to me Steven that more and
more people whatever their color are are
willing to and more courageous about
just calling it out and I'm not
apologizing for it and you gotta stop
apologizing for your your power
ah yeah I think this is your last
segment on a ladder with Crowder because
you're a racist that's what I think I'm
not even gonna lie to you about it I
will say this Michelle so now you
obviously I can never reveal a woman's
age but you're older than I am I think
you can say that without come across is
disrespectful it depends on who you're
talking with sometimes about people
freak out at me but you're older than I
am so you grew up obviously there were
some racial tensions you know here in
the States if you're talking about the
60s I get that right and there are
people who were alive for that and they
haven't forgotten that so I'm not
insensitive to it but my wife and I have
talked about this and all of my friends
and I have talked about this being
raised in a post-racial America you know
being born in the 80s right there is no
systemic established form of
discrimination there hasn't been in my
lifetime okay so that's the America I've
been raised and I just say that to
preface it my wife and I and every
single friend my age have agreed that
racial tensions have never been worse in
our lifetime now is that something that
that you would feel is mirrored with
someone from your generation or would
your kids say that or is it just really
a purely millennial thing because we all
agreed racial tensions are worse now
than ever because of stories like this
where it's constantly brought up where
you have to look at everything through
the lens of race yeah um in the presence
of something that I've been so steeped
in whether it's in academia or having
worked at liberal newspapers and worked
in you know at the Ground zeroes of
racial tension I was in Los Angeles at
the time of the Rodney King riots for
example and
and the you know there's been so many of
these paroxysms that that al sharpton
has been involved and I wouldn't
necessarily say that it's worse than
it's ever been but there's definitely a
feeling under the age of obama of having
to tiptoe and
the political correctness being a you
know 11 on on the meter and i and its
poisonous in the march part because we
have a person in office at 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue who got there and
whose wife got to where she is by
milking and stoking that racial tension
and racial hatred and the double
standard we never talk about the
systemic race and these these people in
Washington never talk about the systemic
racism that's involved for example when
the government is doing it and actively
discriminating against people in the
name of equality and and and and I think
that the lack of truly candid and honest
discussion about race it is probably one
of the most shameful developments of
public policy in the public square in
the last 25 well yeah you're right and
it's it's the racism really of soft
expectations when you're talking about
that yeah and and you know it's funny I
was raised and a lot of people get mad
because I'm white American so it's
automatically you know like I said there
are certain things that I'm completely
insensitive to but you also understand
I'm not a white American I'm an
english-speaking Canadian who was raised
in French Canada where they thought I
was learning disabled until the third
grade because I legally was not allowed
to attend English schools and it turned
out you know French is my first language
I learned to read and write but then you
know obviously we spoke more English at
home and and that's the way I think I
think in English so I was a step behind
everyone because I was doing geography
in French I was doing math in French you
know I can't open Stevens diner because
apostrophe s is an English form of
spelling there is systemic
discrimination in a place like Quebec
I've experienced it and for someone here
in the States to act as others that same
kind of government institutionalized
discrimination it's a real reach and so
people don't don't make that reach they
make the reach that someone asked me to
help them
get there for their Klansmen I mean
that's helpful far we've come in it's
it's great to always hear people like
you who don't take the the BS but I tell
you what as a little as you said as a
little brown woman I'm using your
terminology here I think this and you
can tell me if I'm wrong before Barack
Obama everything was race and it still
been that way right because it's time
for a black president if you don't vote
for him it's you don't it you're a
racist and now everything is war on
women with Lena Dunham faking the you
know lying about the rape to the
Virginia case lying about rape I think
the reason they're doing this war on
women thing right now is they're setting
the stage for Hillary war on women
sexism if you don't vote for her you're
a sexist do you see or someone like an
Elizabeth Warren because I think it'll
be a female candidate do you see that or
am I just being crazy conspiratorial
white guy you know I mean I'm in the
conspiracy camp with you might I be I
definitely see it these progressives
always played a long game and and and
grievance politics has always been their
ticket and they've seen it work in the
past now I would have to say that during
the midterms we finally saw some
pushback in here in Colorado where I
live Cory Gardner was somehow able to
Trump those cards and you know maybe
there's something that other Republicans
can learn from that
I think I think the fact that he never
went still cringed when these ridiculous
arguments were being made was very
effective and also mockery
you know we had mark Udall here who is a
you know to this decrepit old machine
Democrat politician and you when you had
even the liberal media mocking him for
all of the war on women stuff and call
him mark uterus
something is happening you know I'd say
that on the air
that's not allowed that this is actus
airs on an Hunter s turtle radio
Michaele you can't say you we can
actually can start yeah you can't say
that it's scatological apparently yeah
well in any case the the the thing is
that they've worn out their welcome you
know even around the mainstream and
that's a good development no I think
you're right I think they've worn out
there
welcome politically but I do think
culturally they are bombarding young
women right now with this idea that you
know what's funny if this were the case
Michelle if all white men had a secret
meeting behind everyone's back and by
everyone I mean everyone who's not a
white male we said okay we hate everyone
who's not us right we don't even like
women right ready break if that meeting
took place I must have gotten my
invitation must have been lost in the
mail
because the funny thing is and like when
I said earlier you know I said
sweetheart why is it now that if I say
thank you sweetheart it's a term I use
why is it that I'm assumed I either want
to rape that person or oppress that
person and I didn't just mean thank you
sweetheart
that's where we've come as America I
mean it's got to be a shift for you I
mean if people have always been horrible
because I grew up in the generation
where everyone had the youtube comment
section so everything just devolves into
the worst that humanity has to offer
right away but we assume the worst in
everybody now sometimes sweetheart means
sweetheart sometimes hey can you help me
with this a target means I need some
help is that so far-fetched apparently
and you did it such a brilliant job of
answering that that viral get a horrible
cat call video with your trip to the
mall and you know in in the Heartland in
normal America thankfully common
courtesies or star still treated as such
but you know everything becomes of you
know this political grievance Olympics
mom among these people and I you know
whether it's it's Michelle Obama or Lena
Dunham and in and in increasing measures
now these enabling journalists who just
ignore the facts to ply their their
false narratives and I think it shows
why it's so important that you are where
you are fighting in you know fighting in
the podcast space fighting on YouTube
you know to try and get some rebalancing
that of common sense that's that we all
need well the real reason
is my employers look at the actuary
tables and realized that I didn't quite
appeal to the 73 year old male who was
buying some lubricating pocket catheters
I said I guess it's podcast and YouTube
for me but they're but I'm glad that
your children are listening or they're
seeing stuff and I can provide some
stuff for them I mean that's the thing
and Michelle I know you know you have
obviously written books and you've used
traditional mediums as well but what
you've done with so many sites people
don't realize I mean hot-air twitchy
in your own website I mean you made
these mammoth sites before mammoth news
sites existed so sometimes people might
think because you actually stick to your
guns you know she's kind of old corny
Michelle Malkin she's really stuck on
her waist like no you people don't
realize the amount of influence you've
had on new media you in Andrew Breitbart
it's it's staggering and I hope our
listeners are listener I hope our
listeners can appreciate that because I
mean man it's it's something I don't
know if I can do a few you know a few
thousand people are listening to this on
a podcast after it runs to rest really
but twitchy hot air Michelle Malkin I
mean you've had out your hands and so
many things how did you know the old
Wayne Gretzky quote is don't go where
the puck is go where the pucks going to
be how are you so able to see where the
pucks going to be so effectively well I
think just being plugged in and having
my ear to the ground and you know doing
what you're doing which is not getting
stuck in bubbles right and you know
that's a problem not only for a lot of
people who work in our business but you
know for the conservative is for the GOP
establishment writ large and it's
important to be in this space I mean a
you know winning being just being here
is half the battle and and realizing
that the world is so much bigger than a
few cable news stations and a few
mainstream media out well I hate to cut
you off there is yes you are absolutely
right and I hate to cut you off but
there is no small brown lady I would
rather ride into battle with maybe that
little chick from The Incredibles who
made the costume
she seemed like she would probably be
pretty cutting a foxhole but michelle
malkin thank you so much for being here
and last show of the year so we hope to
have you get back here in 22 days my
pleasure